when the schedule came out on Thursday
night one of the things that we all
noticed right out of the gates holy crap
week one is awesome so much for first
four weeks being Inter Conference games
only so they could be postponed chopped
off done away with whatever the NFL has
given us a gift of they could've given
us the 16 worst games on the schedule
week one we've been thrilled
they've given us nine divisional games
they've given us Texans Chiefs race out
the front out of the gates Cowboys Rams
we've got Packers Vikings we've got
Buccaneers Saints round 1 are you
kidding me we got the Steelers in the
Giants to them most storied franchises
in the NFL getting together on Monday
night and and here's the thing Chris and
you know what I did a little poking
around on Friday about this and there is
something to it the NFL my understanding
is this strong degree of determination
to go forward with week 1 week 1 is
happening period and then they'll take a
step back and they'll reassess PR
fallout political fallout medical
fallout what happens when we have a week
of games there's an opportunity to
postpone and or cancel weeks two three
and four week two every team that plays
in week two every game those two teams
have a buy the same week so that we
could be wiped out and those games could
be subsumed into the remainder of the
schedule week three week four no
divisional games now there are games
within the conference or not exclusively
inter conference games but week three or
four both could be put at the end of the
season or could be canceled all together
but there's a window of up to three
weeks after week one for the NFL to take
a step back to reassess and get back to
it now look that's going to create all
sorts of issues from the way of keeping
your players ready but but that's hiding
in plain sight at the front end of the
schedule start with week one and then
step back and see where we are and it's
quite possible games could be postponed
or canceled for up to three weeks based
upon how things go week one well it's
good to see that the NFL has you know
scheduled some flexibility within within
the schedule itself right I mean that to
me is extremely smart
the way they did it you know and then to
make the week one splash and then
reassess hey listen I understand that to
that's extremely smart as well you know
I mean they hey again week one you're
gonna have two teams playing each other
who knows come across the country or
whatever it may be
and yes as we know there's physical
contact and guys sweating on each other
and spit and everything else all around
each other so then you do reassess and
hope that nothing happens I want to say
like if we make it as far as week one
without any issues I feel really good
that we're gonna probably make it to
week two you know again I mean if we can
go through training camp and you know we
haven't heard what the deal is at
preseason yet but if we can get through
some of those hurdles and then feel like
we can get to week one and play you know
football and everybody's safe and
healthy and thing is that you know
looking on the up-and-up then man things
do look good for us to continue the
season from that standpoint I feel like
we're gonna if we're gonna hit hurdles
Mike it's gonna happen before week one
it's gonna happen the first you know the
the second or third week at training
camp or then it's gonna be like oh no
what do we do somebody on the team has
it and we're scrimmaging this team and
now that team has it that's what I worry
about more than anything but nonetheless
we're starting to see the NFL really
well-thought out the schedule and and
has many plans as far as up their sleeve
here in case things go wrong Peter King
spoke at length with dr. Anthony Falchi
you can see that in today's football
morning in America and a variety of
topics regarding how the virus is spread
and would be spread among football
players and basically you're gonna have
virus all over your uniform if you're
blocking or tackling someone who is
shedding the virus that's the technical
term although it sounds far more graphic
than it is I mean if you're coughing the
virus is going into the air and the
virus is going to be on the shoulder
pads the helmet the jersey the pants the
the the the padding everything that
right Honan is wearing and and here's
the thing Peter keeps mentioning he's
done it on the show and I've seen it in
his column he keeps mentioning testing
players twice a week this is one area
where I disagree strongly with Peter I
think and we've had this conversation
you need to basically have an airlock at
the facility no one gets in until they
test negative every time they show up I
mean you could run out for a sandwich
right you leave the facility you must be
tested before you re-enter now again you
may have been exposed to the virus and
you you know I you know I don't know
enough about the science of when you're
positive and when you're negative and
false negatives could be a problem as
well in all of us because somebody could
test definitely they're really not
negative right but two times a week
isn't going to cut it you have to test
and test and test and test and test and
it may be that you test on the way in
every day and you test on the way out
every day and you test I mean if these
tests are going to be as prevalent as I
think they will be you test all the time
because the moment someone's positive
they get yanked out of the bubble before
they can give it to anybody else Chris
so twice a week is not nearly enough
twice a day twice an hour maybe what we
ultimately see by the time we get to
September if we're talking about people
playing football yeah I don't think I'm
with you there you know again twice a
week it's a nice thought but you know -
all the things you said a little bit
before that as far as where the germ and
the the virus could be you know yeah
this is this is football there's just
too much physical contact human contact
people touching you know people touching
each other everywhere they're swapping
of blood I mean come on I was just a
Wimpy quarterback and I would come off
the field in certain games and have
somebody else's blood on my leg or
whatever else I mean that's part of the
sport so I'm with you I don't know how
you could survive but just twice a week
and then yeah okay in between then we're
just gonna hope that guys are clean and
healthy and safe and you know don't
break any guidelines or protocols that
way I just think that's too risky I'm
with you Mike it's gotta be done I think
every morning before you enter the
facility have a little checkup a little
bit what we read in those documents in
the memo that the NFL sent out you know
you're gonna get through you're gonna
get temperature you're gonna get a
series of questions asked for you you're
gonna get basically a quick checkup
every day to make sure okay
you
at least the base regiment the test and
our look test to see if you're okay to
come in this building and not past this
germ around yeah look and I think that
by the time we get into August and
September the world will be dramatically
different than it is now that's a point
Peter makes two months ago today the
world had not yet turned upside down it
happened on the night of March 11 but so
much has occurred in the past two months
and so much is happening behind the
scenes that we don't know about as it
relates to preparation of testing
technological advances understanding
more about the virus and you know I
think we all were kind of oblivious to
how long it takes to really understand
how different pathogens work I just
always assumed that there was this team
of experts that could crack the code
overnight it isn't nearly that simple to
figure out how this all works but by the
time we get into August they're gonna
know a lot more about how it works
they're gonna know more about when if
you show up negative on a test what that
means by way of are you truly out of the
woods and not in a position to actually
have the virus because they just have to
keep this out of the locker room Chris
like you said once something gets into
the locker room it's it's everywhere and
if it gets to three four five guys it's
too late and a team gets shut down and
and I think that may be why they're
doing the week one thing with the
opportunity to wipe out weeks two three
and four it could be it could be that if
if in the aftermath of week one one team
gets shut down they're just gonna shut
the whole league down well right
throughout how far this is spread how
big of a problem it is and then get
ready to come back as late as week five
and trudge through the season if they
can I mean I guess it's entirely
possible although I think not entirely
possible I'd say there's a very small
chance but one of the things we have to
put on the radar screen here is the
chance that they do it week one and then
ultimately realize based upon where the
science is based upon what the virus is
doing and is dr. Falchi told Peter King
the virus makes the decisions for us the
end result could be it's a one-week
season I hope
hell that doesn't happen but I think
it's foolish to not at least consider
the possibilities and folks let me just
say one thing we break the fact that we
are talking about the various
possibilities does not mean we don't
want football to happen we want football
to happen our livelihoods depend upon
football happening but we're not going
to be so pigheaded and stubborn that we
ignore the possibilities and not discuss
the possibilities because if you do that
you're inviting those possibilities to
become reality so anybody who says on
Twitter that I'm rooting for there to be
no season I'm just going to block your
ass moving forward
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports